un alivio para los estudiantes
estadounidenses me quitaron un peso de
encima principalmente para mis padres
porque los estresa mucho
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que perdonará deudas de préstamos a
estudiantes universitarios y recién
graduados el gobierno federal estima que
43 millones de personas se verán
beneficiadas del plan
el costo total para asistir a una
universidad pública de 4 años se ha
triplicado durante los últimos 40 años
en lugar de financiar adecuadamente las
universidades públicas muchos estados
han recortado su apoyo y han reducido la
financiación para sus universidades
estatales dejando que los estudiantes
paguen una mayor parte de la cuenta
esta nueva medida está pensada para
aquellos que ganen menos de 125 mil
dólares de forma individual o 250.000 en
familia anualmente y espera cancelar
10.000 dólares en préstamos y 10.000
adicionales para estudiantes con becas
federales ppl reservadas para quienes
tienen mayores necesidades financieras
el anuncio de bailén ha causado gran
polémica
y no le ha dado una autorización
explícita para sus detractores es visto
como un guiño al voto joven a poco más
de dos meses de las elecciones
legislativas mientras economistas
advirtieron que la medida podría
aumentar la inflación la que llegó al
8.5 por ciento en julio los republicanos
pusieron en duda la autoridad legal del
mandatario para tomar la decisión